this is a girl Courtney she's a welder
hey Theo and Brendan I'm Courtney King
and her sing it for you women doing
blue-collar jobs Gang Gang buzz buzz
did she weld after at the end or no she
didn't do anything after but how was it
that's it is she breaking into a bank
vault what are we doing here she good
she wants to good I like this I like
this lady I like that hard-working lady
right there she's out there Weldon dude
get your hands dirty girl
oh dude she definitely uh she's [ __ ]
John well Bobbitt bro she could [ __ ]
weld your Weiner right off if you don't
behave I respect it I respect it
I'm gonna buy the product I respect the
girl just kidding you wouldn't you did a
female like a weld yeah we'd be cool
she'd well cool [ __ ] for me mmm well
some more of these yeah bottle opener
Steve make us like a metal chair
something fur in hair be nice the
welding's kind of going out of business
yeah yeah 19:15 so out weldings kind of
going our business yeah going out of
business Brendon what do you think keeps
walls up what do you think keeps bridges
up show me a bridge in another country
right now that is fell down Google
bridge falls oh really
kills many Google that and not amen
am I in and ie not that I know her but
that's I'm not talking about her
recently a bridge fell Brendon yeah look
at this one that's Florida is it a
college bro god damn well that's one of
the new-age bridges we mean New Age
bridges dude it's a bridge God dang and
there you go look at that [ __ ] guess you
probably put this grocery guy vehicles
five vehicles first of all that bridge
looks they don't even [ __ ] need it
bro dude get a damn crosswalk dawg
sister then wanted so students can cross
over and sit across from the busy street
and a lot of them crossed right into the
Lord's arms bro
FIU
Oh bro you gotta say this a man for dead
[ __ ] when you when you win
fi you when two of the letters are f you
ain't going there brah I don't believe
in it either fu bruh f su yeah they're
struggling oh they are a grown man they
got Ryan leach I think over there at
quarterback that's not good dude Ryan
yeah I'm down with girls doing this [ __ ]
man it's kind of cool
yeah she's a cutie hell yeah yeah Derek
I'll throw it in your microwave oven
over there with a heat burner right
afterwards you're controlling that ball
did any welder at all well cool hats
wear cool hats you got a free Halloween
costume right when you leave work if you
want we have those cool gloves yeah you
get the best thing is watching somebody
who's winning a welder helmet go order
at a drive-thru and not lift their
[ __ ] thing up god that's gangster Oh
take me to heaven with that bra that
should sexy shout out to this girl you
know your boys qinger knocking the [ __ ]
out of it
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]